e
iniciaram seu projeto de negócio no
secundário no currículo da Sé a
participação na competição a empresa um
programa de empreendedorismo jovem
promovido pela Junior achievement
Portugal Marta Helena Godinho Inês
Antunes e Margarida bracol sou exemplo
de que não há idade para empreender
Oi
Espera aí deixa de fazer sócio que nós
estamos acompanhando o
Oi bom dia eu sou a Inês Antunes Olá eu
sou a Marta Grand essa Catarina vim e eu
sou a Margarida da Costa e nós nos
acessórios vamos falar de um bocado da
nossa experiência enquanto jovens
empreendedoras e tivemos dividir a nossa
história em três fases o início
adjetivação e o sucesso assim achamos
que vocês conseguem perceber melhor
todas as experiências que nós tivemos
durante este último ano tudo começou
quando nosso 12º anos foi feito um
desafio tinham pequena empresa e Nós
pensamos que inicialmente esse ia roubar
muito tempo ia ser muito chato e
abastecer nem empresárias E acima de
tudo empreendedoras o que querem ser
empreendedor E por que que eu tinha de
ser empreendedora nós
começamos o projeto um bocado de pé
atrás e depois convencer antes que podia
ser uma ideia muito gira e nós
resolvemos pegar ela
fizemos alguns brainstormings
inicialmente para tentarmos descobrir
qual seria a nossa ideia de projeto
Esses foram fundamentais porque nós
percebemos que tínhamos descartar ideias
ridículas com a criação de uma casa das
cestas ou os óculos com limpa parabrisas
que ninguém ia comprar e importante
esses bens históricos foram fundamentais
para ideia final só surgiu mesmo quando
numa sexta-feira à noite eu ia sair de
casa com as minhas amigas e abre a minha
sapateira e vi que me faltava o sapato
que eu ia precisar nessa noite como é
que eu ia aguentar uma noite inteira a
dançar com os saldos de 12 centímetros
era completamente impossível então eu
pensei já que eu tenho de criar uma
ideia de negócio aqui é uma ideia que
satisfaça a necessidade das mulheres
então assim surgiu a ideia que é um
sapato de salto alto que o salto é
removível
e esta maneira eu não ia estragar a
minha noite e a continuar a divertir e
resolver o problema de muitas mulheres
no seu dia a dia
e quando extrair A Primeira ideia as
minhas colegas nem pintaram
principalmente a Catarina com caminho
encontra Mas eu percebi que a melhor
maneira de fazer acreditar no projeto
era seu próprio acreditasse e assim foi
fez-se luz sim é verdade que esses luz e
é verdade eu achava que o início esta
ideia não se encontrar bem no conceito
geral da competição e estas opiniões
divergentes causaram alguma desmotivação
apertadas Fontes proposta um primeiro
desafio uma competição a nível regional
com cerca de outras 20 mini empresas
nesta tínhamos que decorar por completo
A nossa banca tínhamos de criar as
estruturas necessárias temos que definir
uma estratégia de marketing para
conseguir atrair as pessoas para a nossa
banca e convencê-los que o nosso era o
melhor projeto estudo no curto espaço de
uma semana e nos pontos quaisquer meios
financeiros e a ser difícil ainda assim
esforçamos e tentamos estabelecer
contactos com diversas empresas Mas
nenhum deles foram corresponde é isso
intensificou o nosso desenho mas eu
percebo nós éramos cinco estudantes do
secundário que nada sabiam sobre plano
de negócios e estruturas de empresas
esse tinha bastante tem causar Nossa
credibilidade numa altura em que o país
não oferece condições de trabalho e de
criação de valor qual seria a empresa
queria aos a sua estabilidade e a sua
credibilidade para ajudar uma simples
miúdas
e isso é o nome das pessoas iriam pensar
porque a ideia que está embutida na
sociedade dos jovens Érica porque
proativos desinteressados com outras
prioridades e não é de novos projetos
novos conceitos e novas ideias
sexta empreendedor agarrar no projeto
desde o início levá-lo até o sucesso e
atendendo a determinação a coragem EA
paixão dos jovens ou empreendedorismo
este caminho processo torna-se mais
intenso mais aliciante mais interessante
é
nesta altura nós ainda não nos sentíamos
como jovens empreendedores ainda não
sentíamos capazes de inverter o
pensamento ainda não tínhamos atingir
este ponto de viragem esse ponto foi
dirigir durante a feira Regional onde
Recebemos um feedback bastante positivo
do Júri e todos os participantes assim
passamos para a feira Nacional o mercado
íntimos conosco colocamos um mercado o
calçado é considerado um nicho
Excelência em Portugal todos o exemplo
da Rihanna está a produzir uma linha de
calçados ao assim passamos por uma
terceira e última fase o sucesso se
aumentar o trabalho de equipa
Conseguimos ver que não sumi não se
consegue até tinha pernas para andar e
demonstramos a todas as pessoas que não
acreditavam em nós que estavam
completamente enganadas e que as Tais
miúdas 12º ano até tinham um até tinham
boas ideias e até conseguiu ir mais além
mas nem tudo é um mar de rosas tivemos
os nossos pontos altos e os nossos
pontos baixos e os nossos pontos altos
de uso exemplo de todas as amizades
criamos das palestras que demos
essencialmente da experiência de todas
as experiência ao longo deste projecto
tem sido incrível e super enriquecedora
os pontos baixos por outro lado com a
Catarina já referiu foi dificuldade para
a feira do jornal onde tivemos um grande
trabalho em apenas uma semana mas
conseguimos e acreditamos que
conseguimos ir mais além uma coisa
bastante interessante durante essa feira
foi que ao demonstrarmos o nosso
conceito não se a paixão pelo que
acreditávamos vimos que as pessoas
acreditavam em nós e e sentiu as mesmas
necessidades que nós esses cones
bastante somos mais paixão ainda para
levar mais além nosso projeto e assim
conseguimos lançar a semente justo era o
nosso o nosso principal objetivo e
sentimos bastante satisfeitas com isso
agora vamos passar um vídeo onde mostra
a paixão a nossa paixão e eu e a reação
das pessoas ao nosso projeto decidimos
sair de casa a espalhar magia pela
cidade de Lisboa a nossa paixão Espero
que Se divirtam tal como nós nos
divertimos
a
escola que você
E aí
a
escola Fielder com 10 und
eu
não sei lá
e as escolas
lojas e
ah é verdade nós mostramos Neste vídeo
que o feedback City Foi bastante
importante para nós os comemos agora
deixa Chaves com as principais ideias
que temos aqui transmitidos nós tivemos
ao longo deste ano contacto presas nem
sempre fomos recebidas da maneira como
queríamos cada passo que nós décimos
podia pôr em causa o nosso lugar tanto
na feira regional como na feira Nacional
na competição nacional e sentimos essa
pressão ao longo deste ano nós
acreditamos fomos que existentes Não
desistimos são características bastante
importantes de empreendedores quer sejam
jovens como nós que essas são adultos
todos que tem que císticas nós
acreditamos que temos somos agora
melhores colegas melhores amigas
melhores empreendedoras temos agora uma
nova visão acreditamos que no futuro nós
estamos na faculdade e daqui a alguns
anos não muito extremos entrar no mundo
do trabalho e é preciso ter algumas
qualidades que nos façam destacar dos
outros é uma Catarina referiu nosso
mercado que neste momento não é o melhor
esse nós percebi isso mas essas
qualidades iríamos ter mais facilidades
e nós achamos que esse projeto nos
ajudou bastante nesse aspecto nós até há
um ano atrás éramos simples alunos do
secundário ou com nada sabiam sobre o
que que era o empreendedorismo que quer
empreender como criar uma empresa um
plano de negócios como falar com os
nossos clientes e nós agora em junho
ganhamos uns empreendedorismo que é
bastante para nós e é visto como o
conhecimento sobre esse trabalho Temos
bastante sou melhores dele ah mas nós
não somos diferentes ninguém mas não
somos melhores não somos mais capazes
sabemos ter ideias é complicado o nosso
grande Senhor me levou algum tempo nos
sentimos são poder arranjar uma ideia
tínhamos prazo e mesmo que as ideias
surja Como surgiu a nós não sabíamos se
era possível o valor o sucesso que é
importante aqui é acreditar não desistir
um sobressalto e levar em frente essa
vossa ideia só supor Gente esse sonho
por exemplo vocês vocês podem criar como
nós a vossa própria empresa ou quem sabe
tá certo aprender a falar Mandarim Quem
não gostaria ou melhor ainda ele
trabalhava a você em Nova York qualquer
um de nós gostaria trabalhar em Nova
York porque o que tanto aqui é Basta
Querer para ser porque qualquer um pode
ser empreendedor pois empreendedores nas
em qualquer lugar e em qualquer
circunstância obrigado por nos terem
ouvido Nós somos as mechas
Oi Cláudia